one of the reasons that various
commenters and the authorities tend to
be anxious about the future is that
things are in a sense getting out of
control
transcendence the disinformation
encyclopedia of transhumanism and the
singularity is a new book from writers
Jay Cornell and are you serious both
former editors of futurist magazine h+
and long-time chroniclers of
transhumanism which is the belief that
humans should hack their bodies and
minds with technology to achieve better
and longer lives covering topics ranging
from artificial intelligence to cryonics
to cyborgs to sexbots the book is a
compendium of nearly every subject or
term important to futurists
transhumanists and cingulate Aryans
reason TV sat down with Cornell and
Sirius to talk about the history and the
future of technological development the
politics of futurism and how rapid
decentralization is changing the way
innovation happens somebody came around
today from 20 30 years ago they would
see self-driving cars emerging they
would see some robotics replacing a
number of forms of employment and labor
they would see everything having gone
digital I mean the entire economy in the
entire world having gone into what we
used to call cyberspace and that's just
a huge transformation that that in
itself is science-fictional and then the
next stage is likely to be bodily
enhancements already we see people with
cyborg enhancements that in some ways
might be an improvement we see 3d
printing of organs so I were right on
that cusp where some of the science
fictiony elements
transy envision is coming to to be I
think NBIC is one of the concepts that
some people feel is driving forward this
future so there's a nanotechnology which
in theory is the control over the
molecular structure of matter
there's biotechnology which in theory is
control over biology there's information
technology which we all know and are
familiar with and possibly leading
towards this concept of the singularity
of developing intelligences that are
greater than our own and there's
cognitive science which sort of overlaps
with information science the enhancement
of our intelligence figuring out how to
use our brains perhaps how to unite our
nervous systems and brains with the a
eyes to avoid the Skynet scenario you
know don't put your a I in charge of
nuclear weapons launch without a little
human circuit-breaker
in the middle there but there are
scenarios in which something relatively
innocent could could turn bad personally
I'm worried that somebody is going to
get their little DNA machine and decide
to cleanse the world of humans or
whatever by producing some sort of super
smallpox or super Ebola in their little
garage laboratory that sort of thing is
going to be hard to protect against
because when the technology spreads and
so many people get ahold of it chances
are there's going to be somebody with
bad intentions it could be that
transparency is actually going to be the
thing that will help us and in the sense
of having lots of eyes almost all eyes
on almost everything that's being done
whether we call surveillance everybody
watching everybody else as difficult as
I find this personally the possibility
that everybody will just be intimately
watching everybody else by the time
we're
we're producing these kinds of scenarios
could be it could be a saving grace
embolizing for most of human history
people didn't really hate and have a
concept of technological progress you
know the technology of their
great-grandparents was the same as
theirs and you know history might change
because kings were born and died and
empires would rise and fall but the
technology didn't really change and it
was really only in the last few hundred
years that people started realizing that
there could be these inventions that
really mattered and that really changed
the way that people did farming or
whatever by the 19th century you had a
great deal of optimism all that this
sort of Jules Verne HD or early HD
Welles stuff and so in the 20th century
you had a great deal of technological
progress but a great sort of
centralization of a lot of it where at
the beginning the Wright brothers could
build their airplane in their bicycle
shop and 50 years later
nobody was building a jet fighter in a
bicycle shop it was just not not
possible and a lot of people felt that
trend was inevitable and yet with the
whole maker revolution 3d printers that
people can buy there's a great
decentralization of this going on and I
think that's one of the reasons that
various commenters and the authorities
tend to be anxious about the future is
that things are in a sense getting out
of control they cannot control exactly
who is saying what over the Internet and
who is communicating with what and who
is building what in their in their
garage there's a history of transient
ISM and libertarianism the extra pians
where the original transient they had a
strong libertarian orientation although
there were people in the extra payin
group who were liberals or leftists or
Marxist a lot of people I interacted
with were pre centrist actually
they had a libertarianism of the body in
the brain because they all believe that
human being should be allowed to enhance
themselves they should be allowed to
test things without the FDA interfering
with it
there are even now people who talk about
in the book called grinders who are
doing sort of scalpel level experiments
on their own bodies implanting magnets
in their fingertips so that they can
sense magnetic fields and they're doing
this with scalpels and vodka and ice
cubes and without without any any
permission
I think self experimentation is pretty
much out of control right now and I
don't I don't see a great tendency to
want to control it on the part of the
state I mean the interesting thing may
be when some small group of hackers
biotech hackers or or or whatever
actually come up with say a longevity
treatment or a formula that seems like
it might be realistic